hi I'm Shoni and I'm here to show you
how you can implement alpha go and the
implementation straight
methods that we use to implement alphago
and go turns out that we ended up asking
some very fundamental questions and
we'll explore some of that as well but
what I really want to show is that small
teams can actually make some progress to
the big questions of building and AGI
now if it doesn't matter if you don't
know anything about neural networks
because that's what I'm going to explain
everything from scratch big task now in
2016 alpha alpha go was built by Google
and it beats lee sedol
the world champion ago and it's been two
years since alphago itself has became a
family of algorithms and the latest of
which is called alpha zero I don't work
for Google and so I want you to be
mindful that when I talk about alphago I
mean my implementation of alphago so why
implements alphago ingo well one of my
favorite programming languages is go and
I really like wordplay and when it was
announced that alphago is not actually
written in go it was written in C++ and
Python and tensorflow hands liked it
that really bugged me I really really
love wordplay so much so that my
colleague JD actually suggested that if
it were possible for me to implement L
alpha go in go on the alpha the DC's
alpha architecture I would have done it
and that's true right but seriously
there are some very good reasons for
re-implementing alpha go and go but
before that I want to introduce to you
the cast of characters the people who
helped make this happen
we're comprised of four guys who are
essentially people who work in the
machine learning fields we're not
unfamiliar with building and deploying
neural networks so why do it n go well
there are many reimplementation of
alphago out there the most famous of
which is Leela but they're all written
in Python and tensorflow
now I've got nothing against Python all
tensorflow
I actually run the Python meetup in
Sydney but I value diversity
having a by having a diverse number of
implementations that mature shows the
different issues that may exist to date
I think we're the only alpha zero
implementation it's completely outside
of Python and tensorflow so how do you
implement alpha go in go to do that we
relied on go go Nia go Nia is a family
of library for for deep learning and go
and a little bit of history here I was
actually quite frustrated with
tensorflow not sensible piano back in
the day so I wrote gorgonian and about
six months after I did that about six
months after I did that Google announced
and released tensorflow having some FOMO
syndrome I decided to release tens of
corneum
now whoa this is weird huh
how gorgonian works is very similar to
how tensorflow and Pye Tosh works
basically you start by creating an
expression graph a bit of site notes
here I see that a few blank faces so if
you've used tensorflow or Cara's do you
mind raising your hands and it may
escape your attention that what you're
actually doing is building an expression
graph an expression graph is a
representation of a mathematical
expression and I put it to you right now
that all neural networks are
mathematical expressions this is a
typical image that you see when people
talk about neural networks now it's
useful to use images like these to
communicate what a neural network is but
it's not entirely accurate right this I
think is a much more accurate
representation of a single layer of a
neural network and the genius of this
equation is that it combines two things
linear transformation and a non linear
transformation doing so allows this
function to approximate any other
functions as long as you have the
correct values in order for you to have
the correct values you need to learn the
values and in order to learn the values
some parts of this expression needs to
be changeable in this expression its W
and B that is learn about they learn
from good and bad examples
back propagation and gradient descent we
call them weights to understand back
propagation we must first evaluate the
expression and we call it y hat the
predicted value and earlier what's
happening and then we need to calculate
the difference between the actual Y and
the predicted Y we call that Z or in
America we call it Z so the smaller your
Z is the better your neural network is
so how do you make your Z small well
recall from earlier that the weights are
changeable so the solution is quite
simple you simply change your weights
and your biases to make Z as small as
possible and over the last 300 years
we've learned how to do this it's called
differentiation you simply differentiate
your output with regards to your input
the difference tells you how much to
change your weights and because we're
fancy when you use it in the context of
neural networks we call it back
propagation but reality is it's just
your basic high school chain rule now
it's just not enough to know how much
should change W and B it's also
important to update your W and B's and
your weights to reflect the changes
these are called gradient updates and
because Z is typically small and you
typically start from big number it's a
descent so we call it gradient descent
now the standard gradient descent
methodologies use in typical deep
learning is much more complex than the
one that you see here but the point is
that you get a picture in general
Gorgo Nia takes care of back propagation
and takes care of gradient descent
automatically so we only really need to
worry about the forwards algorithm now
now that we know that new networks are
essentially mathematical expressions we
can represent them as code and if you're
familiar with Lisp this is how it may
look like now the reason why I bring
this up is because in order to be in
order to fully understand something I
believe you need to see the same thing
from different points of view and
another way to view a neural network is
that it's a function that is still being
written every time the weights change a
new function is being
generates it and your function may be
something as simple as addition or it
may be a function it takes an image and
retells you whether it's a hot dog or
not so the idea is then to find the
weights to funk to to generate the
correct function and you may compare
this with lambda calculus a lambda and
lambda calculus generates a new function
a neural network generates a new
function and functions as you know may
be encoded as lambda terms or they may
be encoded as girdle numbers or in this
case the encoded simply as a bunch of
matrices and like any function it may
also be represented as streams see one
of the things that you start finding out
after you do this for some time is that
trees are everywhere
there is some sort of universality to
trees and Barry Jay has something quite
interesting on on the universality of
trees in his upcoming paper I recommend
reading it I had to cut quite a number
of slides from this talk when I talk
about trees because I tend to get quite
excited about it but come find me after
the talk if you want to talk about
encoding programs as trees or lambda
calculus or tapes or girdle numbers or
matrices which are essentially modern
variants of g-strings so having an
expression represented as a tree allows
us to understand how it is to be
evaluated you ask me like any ast you
start from bottom you fill up the leaves
with values and you work your way up and
this in a nutshell is how neural network
works by the way the expression I showed
that's called a fully connected layer so
the next bit we need to know off is
convolutions and according to my notes
here a convolution is a transformation
that preserves the spatial features of
the input blah blah blah it's a very big
mouthful so to make things a bit more
concrete we have a hypothetical board
game with crosses and notes and we wish
to convoke this board with a 3x3 matrix
that looks like this instead of
representing the board with crosses and
notes let's represent them as a bunch of
numbers a matrix of numbers the current
player is a cross so we'll say the that
crosses are ones and minus ones are the
notes
empties our zeroes su yes it is and so
we start our convolution process the
convolution starts by us overlaying the
kernel on top of the matrix because the
kernel is a three by three it does not
cover the entire board so we need to do
this in multiple steps to calculate the
result is simple we simply multiply the
values element-wise and then we sum it
up in this case because everything else
but the center of the kernel is a 1 the
sum is 1
after that we slide to the right and
then we repeat the process the sum is
now minus 1 and we can continue doing so
until the entire board has been fully
convolve here I want you to notice two
things one is that the result is a 3 by
3 matrix second is that the result is a
exact copy of whatever it is in the
middle of the 5x5 board now 3 by 3 as a
result is because of the way I use
convolutions I specifically use
something called unpadded convolution
you could of course pad the board make
it 7 by 7 and when you run the same
convolution you will get a 5 by 5 board
as its result the fact that is its exact
copies because of the kernel I use we
call it the identity kernel the one with
the one in the middle and as its name
suggests it returns a copy of the
original there exists other kernels of
course and that's exactly what we want
to learn recall from earlier a neural
network is comprised of linear
transformations and non-linearity
applied to it well what do I say a
convolution was again a bunch of
multiplications and in a summation it is
a linear operation and hence the goal of
the neural network is to learn the
kernel finally we need to talk about
neural network architectures in order to
understand how alpha zeroes neural
networks work I'm gonna introduce
another way of representing neural
networks this way ooh this way and I've
introduced a fully connected layer I've
introduced the convolution layer earlier
the deep neural network is similar
except with more layers
having a deep neural network is cool
everyone's doing it nowadays the
accuracy of your prediction increases as
you add the number of layers but that's
cheating as you add the number of layers
you're essentially adding the number of
knobs and dials you get to control your
function parameters so to speak but when
you have more knobs and dials than width
then your data points you're gonna run
into weird things like high training
error rates or overfitting you don't
want to do that so a bunch of smart
people from Microsoft observed that in
order to fix such a problem you simply
need to make a copy of the input and add
it to the output before applying
non-linearity this is called a residual
neural network with this we now have the
fundamentals to build alphago alphago in
its core is surprisingly simple there
are only two components first ooh first
there is a new network that detects
patterns on a board and it makes
decisions on where to place the next
stone the architecture looks something
like this
and I want you to notice something the
neural network returns a policy and a
value a policy is essentially a decision
on what actions to take next it's a list
of probabilities and each cell in that
list is a represents placement to place
a stone the value is what economists
would call an expected value how much
the the policy is worth and that is all
the neural network does now the second
component is actually the interesting
part is good old-fashioned AI when the
alphago paper first came out I was not
warmed to the idea but the more I
thought about the problem space the more
I thought that was a very very brilliant
idea by the time I offer zeros paper
came out I was sold see ooh see the
policy indicates what the best action is
and really the question is is it the
best action well to do that
alphago needs to figure out what the
opponent's may do so in order to do that
let's imagine ourselves to be part of
alphago and we're playing a game of
tic-tac-toe the board positions our
index as such
zero to eight and the game is in
mid-flight so we've got a policy now
that says that we've got a place and not
in position to is this really the best
place what if we place it here and up
opponents places it on position six
these kinds of counterfactual questions
are answered by the Monte Carlo tree
search and it looks something like this
it basically goes through as many
possible scenarios as possible and that
is the genius that lies at the heart of
alphago is the way it treats and
approaches searches when you have a huge
search base you need to constrain your
search space and that's what the neural
network does by releasing its policy it
constrains how wide to search and though
the value essentially constrains how
deep to search and then after that the
neural network alphago itself finalizes
on a decision and the actions taken the
game continues and that's in a nutshell
how alphago works so we now turn our
focus to zero it's called zero because
there's no training data from humans
required the way it works is quite
simple a new network plays a game
against itself the games being recorded
and used as a training data for a new
neural network once that new know the
new neural network is trained you pit
the old versus the new and if the new
wins past a certain proportion of time
we use the new network as the de-facto
network we simply rinse I repeat and now
we've eliminated the requirements for us
to exist just joking okay so now we're
ready to talk about implementation and
if you listen to detractors there is a
lot of disgruntlement about go no
generics if R is not nil half but really
the new network of alpha zero is rather
straight forwards it's simple enough
that I can show you the forwards
algorithm in one slide and the algorithm
for the self play bit is also quite
straightforward right again it can be
shown in one slide
look the point here is not for you to
read the code it's available in the
repository for your leisurely perusal
later on the point I'm trying to make
here is that it's not that difficult
so implement alpha zero using go
deployments is equally simple just run
go run go build and if you want to use
CUDA and and Excel accelerate your
processing use the flag the CUDA flag I
can build for Windows
I can build for Mac OS and I can build
for Linux all with a single flag change
that said I've got a live version of
alphago running my my implementation
anyway so what oh sorry
let's try to move this to mirror all
right there you go this is a live
version and it's supposed to run inside
the presentation but unfortunately I
could not see what's happening so we can
actually play and here you can see the
output and policies of what a neural
network does and this is a Gamecock
comeno relation to james no one gets
that ok fine if you if you if you play
warframe you might be familiar with this
game it's a mini game inside warframe
it's like it's go with additional
constraints in the sense that once a
player captures three stones the game
ends so this neural network that I had
was trained last night bad idea to start
training things last night right so it's
not it's not going to be as smart as it
can be and it doesn't play well with
aggressive gameplay styles so let's just
quickly finish up
what's this I have no idea what I did
there but okay there you go um 20 versus
14.5 with all the neural networks you
can see which weights are being which
positions are being placed nicely so
having said that what's hard about
making alphago
clearly I don't know what happened
mirror am I correct you just separate
displays there you go
presentations are hard no matter how
much you practice it's still hard why is
it only Google that managed to you know
do it well the first bit that was hard
for me was MCTS the version of MCTS I
have in the repository is something like
the sixth time I've tried to write it
it's hard to test it's hard to get right
and it's hard to make it perform and the
second hard part for me was go the game
the rules of the game is surprisingly
intricate and really helps if you know
the game when I started this I did not
know how to play none of our team knew
how to play go and the problem with not
knowing how to play means that you're
not able to evaluate whether it is good
or not but really the last hard part the
real hard part is the main reason why it
takes big companies like Google to
master go training is hard it is very
very hard it uses a lot of resources GPU
and CPU and TPU and you might say hey we
live in the cloud era no put it in the
cloud distribute your trainings well
that alone brings its own headache right
recall earlier from earlier that a
neural network again I'm repeating this
because it is a mathematical expression
and it learns using back propagation and
gradient descent so let's get rid of
noise and let's imagine that there are
multiple copies of the neural network
each sitting on a different easy to box
the neural networks all did their back
and forward propagation and now they've
got gradients now it's time to update
the weights you cannot update it per
machine because they're all technically
supposed to be the same machine same
neural network you need instead
something like like a parameter server
to be the master copy but then when you
start doing things like that you have to
start worrying and contending about
Network latency processing speed what
happens if a child does not process in
time
well you gotta wait an alternative would
be to use an asynchronous method like
hog-wild
so you don't have to wait for everyone
to finish you just update your gradients
as it goes along but that makes your
parameter server a lot more complicated
and even with the language that is
excellent at concurrency like go this is
quite a hassle Google has quite a
monopoly over the AI development space
with tensorflow with Google Cloud and
TPS and here here I can see that they
have the high ground because everything
is so integrated of course I'm not one
to run from a fight
though I will admit at one point I did
give up you see I had miscalculated how
much it would cost to run this on AWS
and I was off by two magnitudes I recall
the conversation quite well we were
having burgers and we were ready to
massively deploy this thing and Darrow
and Gareth who like you really want to
spend seventy thousand dollars on this
thing and I was like what do you mean
seventy thousand dollars I calculated
any cost 700 No so we frantically
recalculate at it and my heart sank
there was no way we wouldn't get a nice
model that would be comparable to the
one that beat Lisa at all so I stopped
caring about alphago I stopped caring
about the go playing part see since I
was a kid I've always wanted to build an
artificial intelligence what we call a
GIS nowadays the project was the first
time in quite some time that I had been
very excited over a project and to give
you some context prior to this project I
had just shut down my startup it turns
out nobody wants to pay money for a
compiler that compiles English
probabilistically into a program and I
was at a very low point in my life and
this project was something that I looked
forward on working on every day but now
staring back at me was all the work that
we had done for nothing now of course
the project was not work done for
nothing as they say necessity is the
mother of invention and in facing these
challenges I believe we've done some
very interesting things and the novelty
was enough to keep me satisfied I like
to share some of them with you and I
want to point out that these are not all
good ideas most of them are harebrained
ideas and most of them turned out
be failures we started by saying huh
that's a good idea we can publish a
paper about this and after the results
came back it's not maybe not but the
seeds are in place for something weird
and interesting to happen so instead of
continuing with our original plans we
started to ask questions in increasing
generality the first questions that we
asked was what other ways are there to
improve training speed well the answer
was quite simple you train with
different things so the first thing that
we looked at was how we did distribute
that training we took a cue from work
done on synthetic gradients and rolled
with it the idea is simple instead of
having to wait for all the gradients to
come in through a server use the
individual gradients on each individual
machine and adjust it with some sort of
things we chose to use an in-between
server latency as the multiplier and we
had a linear regression model to predict
the incoming gradients as crazy as this
sounds this idea is actually quite
rooted in the physical systems in your
body
we've got something called Ephron's and
reference systems which essentially acts
as the cache for your motor systems and
using noisy adjustments from network
latency well that's like simulating a
spiking neural network which is what
happens in your brain the idea turns out
to be not useful the network latency
distribution of AWS was not ideal for a
use case but I think here is something
interesting that can be kept in view and
might be quite useful in the future so
thinking about synthetic gradients
allowed us to explore really different
ideas that are not found in mainstream
deep learning literature right one of
the things that we did was to play
around with something called particle
swarm optimization I worked as a guide
Delaney Gillian from Las Vegas on PSRs
and what it does is essentially instead
of using back propagation to find the
gradients and then change the values
using gradient descent the weights are
changed randomly and you have a particle
swarm of sources that push through the
weight changes in a particular direction
the results were interesting
it worked but on the whole it was slower
than gradients and gradient descent I
guess is the main reason the main reason
we were using gradient descent and deep
learning is because it it works and
works fast and it also uses a lot of
memory now I mainly attribute that to do
my testing and playing around code but I
definitely see some potentials in using
PSO this is because PSO can be massively
parallel lized
and it does not get stuck at local
minimize move now the PSL library of
gogo Nia is not quite ready for
primetime yet so but if you snoop around
a github organization you might actually
find it furthermore using PS OS required
us to rethink how neural networks are
structured and on the whole that's not
anything too major but I was not ready
to throw away years of knowledge so we
took a step back and ask the question
what is the goal the goal at that point
was still to play go somewhat well and
so after some periods of frustration I
said we should just use transfer
learning to bootstrap the network you
can think of transfer learning as
refactoring if a neural network is a
function or program then transfer
learning is refactoring we often copy
the bodies of functions and place them
in new functions when we refactor write
transfer learning is something like that
principle is simple you've got two tasks
that are marginally related to one
another so let's say the first task is
an image recognition neural network that
you've trained from work it's comprised
of a convolution and other convolution
layers and other layers and the second
task is the alpha zero neural network
now the key thing is that these tasks
share something in common and the idea
is that you just need to copy over the
parts that you want you've already
learned and as a result you only need to
train on a small part here I want to
take a sidebar because when you build
neural networks and complex systems like
this it's often a good idea to take the
same thing build the same thing but test
it on a smaller scale we test that and
our implementation works by building
different games for the neural network
to play same neural network plays
tic-tac-toe play
is connect for place Comey and these
smaller games with smaller search spaces
allowed us to actually verify that
things are working correctly so in the
spirit of transfer learning the idea was
that you first train on each small task
train on Tic Tac Toe trainer Connect
four and then transfer the weights to
the bigger network but in order to
properly do this you need to actually
understand what the neural network is
learning right tic-tac-toe is a three by
three board go has 19 by 19 board having
to scale that up requires some fine
understanding of what exactly is
happening at some points we all got a
bit frustrated and asked the question
what if the neural network just learned
all the games at once so there are two
ways to do this the first way is to
share share all the weights in a
transfer learning style and the second
way requires a special encoding of the
input and this results in doubt to be
quite well so the model that the daemon
that we saw earlier was built on top on
a base of off a bunch of training or
based on multiple games at once in the
final layers in last night I was just
giving it some final pushes to focus
specifically on Komi yeah now the work
on multi task learning showed some
promise so it was us then then very
useful for us to step back and ask what
is alphago good for why did Google spend
at least thirty five million dollars on
it oh it turns out alphago is quite
related to Google's core business search
and recall that I said that the newer
Network essentially constrains the
search right and that's the same reason
why alpha zero is being used to search
for cancer drugs and other kinds of
drugs you know what else has a large and
infinitely large search space optimum
neural network weights so you can guess
what we tried to do next we fed our
version of alpha go into alphago it took
quite a bit of thinking about how to
model the policies and values and the
network architecture had to be changed
quite a bit but after about 200 bucks of
spending on AWS we will ready to call it
quits nonetheless I still think it's
important that we did that you see I
think it opened up the big questions if
anyone's familiar with Turing's paper on
the halting problem feeding alphago into
itself might seem somewhat familiar so
that led to the question are we almost
there - implementing an AGI now I've
briefly mentioned AG eyes before but
I've neglected to give a definition this
is because the term AGI is very nebulous
different people have different
understandings of what this for me I
believe that an AGI needs to have these
three things and needs to be able to
understand cause and effect you need to
be able to compute and you need to be
able to handle a wide variety of
problems now humans are causal
reasoner's for the most part we
understand innately within us cause and
effect I hit my head are in the museum
on Wednesday and I immediately
understood that the pain came from me
hitting my head not from someone kicking
me right so per you dipole a causal
reason I can do these three things they
can see patterns they can interfere and
take actions and most importantly they
can imagine alternative scenarios can
alphago do the same here's how our girl
works again it clearly sees pens but can
alphago imagine alternative scenarios
well I'm being obi-wan here and says
from certain perspective yes it can
albeit in a very very limited sense
right within the allowed action space so
to speak
lastly alphago can definitely take
actions but not interfere so contrary
you Darryl I think alphago is somewhat
of a causal reasoner humans can think
about thinking that's unique according
to Chomsky that's the only thing that
sets us apart from other animals and
computation is all about recursion can
alphago computes I had mentioned earlier
that we fed our version of alpha going
to alphago but there was another fluke
that led to this for
that alphago might be recursive so very
early on we trained a neural network on
tic-tac-toe and as you may know the best
move to make in 6xo is to not play at
all so it turns out the neural network
and the MCT is all agreed that the best
move is to make a pass and because the
opponent was running the same network it
went something like this past past past
past past past past and it never ended
this took about two hours worth of
training time in which is about the same
amount of time that Matthew Broderick
took to find out about mutually assured
destruction now I want to be clear the
only reason why training on tic-tac-toe
let you know that an infinite loop was
due to a confluence of two things one
the way we designed our neural networks
was that we had passed as a valid action
space and two it was the way we assigned
values through wins losses and draws but
this makes it clear and alphago like
system is actually capable of running
into the halting problem it's not a
proof of recursive 'ti but it goes to
reason that alphago like systems can
compute the latest nano paper is a
particularly interesting exploration on
the topic I would encourage everyone to
read that now lastly humans are able to
tackle a vast array of causal
computation problems we don't have a new
network in our brain that plays chess
specifically that's nuts we can play
chess we can play tic-tac-toe we can
write go and play go earlier I had
mentioned that our reimplementation was
trained on mix of games so I'm gonna say
it is possible to architect a new
network that is able to tackle multiple
things at once
I think it's early days though and
they'll think that I'm quite interested
in playing with is having an attention
network in the middle so that we don't
have to encode the inputs specifically
to the game so I'm gonna mark that I say
yes now in this talk I've gone through
the basics of the neural network and
then I've introduced the architecture
for alpha zero and this is the
repository due to a number of issues I
cannot actually
created this but it will be created by
the end of this weekend now I had also
recounts at various experiments that we
tried in order to overcome some resource
constraints and all of the experiments
that I described may just appear to be
some sort of unfocused exploration but
throughout this talk I hope I've made
clear that there are two consistent
themes the first is of resource
constraints ooh the search for the best
play is constrained by the new network
all right but in real life resource
constraints that happen out of money
I'm not geoff hinton I'm not demis
hassabis and I doubt anyone would just
give me money to run my own AI laughs
that said if any of you want to give me
money I won't say no to that
see I had to get creative I had to try
very much different things which brings
me to the second theme of this talk
diversity I truly believe that new
networks both in our brains and on
silicon are better off if they're
exposed to a greater multitude of things
and by by an analogy diversity of
implementations in a diverse set of
languages only adds to our collective
strength of understanding what neural
networks are for the record I don't
consider that by various bindings to
tensorflow in various languages to
really be adding to the you know
diversity of implementations now I'm
talking about things like gogo Nia and
go DL for J in Java grenade in Haskell
Orca nets and Julia they're much more
interesting I strongly believe that more
love more support should be given to
these libraries having said that I am
biased I am after all the creator of
cocoa Nia so take that with a pinch of
salt but I will say this the questions
that we asked and and came up with all
these we had philosophical questions we
would never have asked if we simply did
the boring thing and implemented it in
tensorflow now I strongly believe that
there is a deep connection between the
universality of Trees programs and
neural networks recently there was a
paper by Spivak that said that back
propagations can be viewed as functors
and if you read the paper carefully
backpropagation can be seen as lenses so
that's a good clue there that
there's some sort of deep connections
and there is so much more to explore
I believe that small teams do better in
this case I sure that you don't need
much resources to experiment on the
weirder ideas that expose immediately
the fundamental questions although
granted at this point in time only the
large players like Google are actually
able to experiments at scale I'm
personally quite split on that on the
one hand you get really really cool
stuff for alphago on the other hand
resource centralization means
monopolization of tech and knowledge and
I don't you know it's I'm not
comfortable with that so I really really
believe that it's time to build an AGI
and it should not be in the hands of
corporations what we need is a dice
borer of different implementations of
the weirder parts with the ideas and we
should make it known I've shown that for
people who mainly works over the
weekends can do quite a lot and I'm
excited for what's to come next
go forth and diversify oh thank you
[Applause]